pandas have the bodies of carnivores but  they don't eat like them instead they  die and almost exclusively on bamboo  herbivores have twisty guts and  microbial helpers to get the most from  their veggies the question is how do  pandas get the energy they need from  their restricted diet the answer they  don't move around too much when  scientists measured the energy  expenditure of pandas they found it was  extremely low wild pandas expand about  45 percent of the energy expected from a  comparable mammal pandas also have  slimmed down organs with lower energy  demands and lower levels of thyroid  hormones which slows their metabolism  now you know the next time you see a  panda relaxing in the Sun slowly eating  bamboo they have a good reason